[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring in bob harrig he's there at the
open championship sports illustrated
golf writer and author of the book tiger
and phil golf's most fascinating rivalry
uh released in april
how would you describe the scene this
morning when uh tiger took the
microphone in front of the media
hey dan yeah well
it's always a interesting scene people
are keen to hear what tiger has to say
and
we see him so little these days given
the injuries that he suffered in a small
amount of golf that he's playing
so there was a lot to get to i think we
wanted to know about his health and why
he's able to have been practiced so much
here this week and obviously
there's a lot of other issues in the
game that he touched on quite a bit i
think a lot more than than we
anticipated
how many of these interviews happen
without the question of the live tour
coming up
almost zero now
especially
okay especially among the prominent
players it's just been such a
um you know
uh big topic in the game it's it's it's
been disruptive to the game
uh
we've got so many name players that have
gone
uh and
and there's a bunch of them here
obviously uh playing in the open this
week uh
that are eligible and and and it's
caused some awkwardness frankly you know
there's
you know tiger was pretty strong about
it today there's some guys who are very
upset
that uh these players have made this
decision and and you know we really
don't quite know where this is all going
to go
greg norman was not invited
he's won the open championship twice
no matter what you think of the live
tour was it fair to not invite
a former champion
to me no i i think they made it worse by
doing that
um they more they called more attention
to it they put out a statement on
saturday which caused us all to write
about it um norman knew for at least a
week that he hadn't
that he hadn't been invited and uh i
don't think he was out there making a
big deal out of it
and had greg been here this week he
would have probably taken part in that
champions
event on monday that tiger was in lee
trevino a lot of the past champions
i don't think greg was going to go out
of his way to be disruptive or
or or do anything that was going to
distract from the open he did win it
twice
um he could have attended the champions
dinner tonight had he so chosen now i
mean in their defense
norman did piss
did
take a chance
pass on a chance in in 2015
to play his final open here at st
andrews he was 60 then
60s the age limit
and and chose not to and chose not to
take part in the champions event so you
know maybe some of it stems from that
too but uh
you know they could have invited him and
let it be his decision
how does it work when they pick do they
pick who they're going to put in front
of the media therefore if they don't
want to give bryson to shambo or dustin
johnson or patrick reed the opportunity
to be on stage
is it done that way that it's you know
we're going to pick the top players and
they decided not to include the lib tour
yeah i mean pretty much i mean there's
there's a
there's a pretty obvious list of guys
that that we'd like to get in here um
you know obviously the defending
champion morikawa scheffler won the
masters justin thomas won the pga matt
fitzpatrick won the u.s open you'd like
to have them you'd maybe like to have
some past champions of the open
dustin johnson would have qualified phil
mickelson would have qualified certainly
i mean last year phil nicholson won the
pga championship
you know and he's almost
not been discussed this week
yeah i think it was i don't think it was
a coincidence that none of the live guys
were invited in i mean louis hazen who
won the open here in 2010
and lost in a playoff here in 2015.
so the last two opens here he was very
much part of the story
was seconded two majors last year and
third at another
he might be a guy we'd want to talk to
but he's part of the live tour and they
chose not to bring him in
is phil
been around i mean is he being phil
mickelson thumbs up and all of that
yeah phil's been out there practicing um
you know but put stand very much in the
background you know um
uh he elected not to to to be part of
that champions
event on monday and and
it's my understanding he's not going to
the champions dinner tonight
um
that kind of tells you where we are i
think i mean
before all this phil is a beloved figure
in the game you know 30-year history
yeah and now he's sort of you know
taking himself out of these things and
he's obviously got a lot of criticism
it's just a strange place we find
ourselves in in golf right now
how do things play out this week bob
good question i think a lot of it
depends on the weather you know the old
course st andrews
lots of fears that it just has not
withstood the test of time or that it
won't
um and
it's so weather dependent
not had any rain it's very firm very dry
it's been windy if it continues to be
windy then i think it gets really
interesting
because you know a guy like scheffler
never played here before this week
justin thomas has never played in the
open here
matt fitzpatrick says the course doesn't
really suit him
you know i it it does it just brings in
so much doubt when you don't know how
far the ball is going to run on hard
greens
and hard ground and when the wind blows
if it's calm tony fino said i can hit a
wedge to every par four i'm not sure we
really want that so it's gonna be really
interesting to see how the weather plays
out and you know i think a lot of guys
have a great chance this week you know
rory's you guy you mentioned earlier i
think we're all looking to see how he
might fare
i was telling the audience uh that the
17th tee box and
you know you got a hotel in front of you
um right you know i i've had trees in
front of me and you know i've had you
know water in front of me not many times
you have a hotel in front of you and i
know that that it doesn't affect the
pros
but if you're an amateur and you're on
that tee box
uh
what what were your thoughts the first
time you played it and you tried to hit
it over the corner of that hotel
you know if you designed a hole like
that today you'd be vilified
i mean it just wouldn't it just wouldn't
happen i mean you get you'd get scorched
for for even suggesting it and and you
know you say it doesn't affect the pros
i was watching the practice round on
sunday with tiger and jt and justin
thomas hid it into the hotel
in fact
when he when he hit the tee shot he
screamed out hit a window he was mad at
himself obviously and it landed like in
a like in a little uh patio area of the
hotel so it's
in play i mean it was ob but you can hit
it over there there's that there's that
old railway shed that says old course
hotel and everybody says you aim over
the o
in the word course and it's just it's
disconcerting i watched lee trevino
yesterday took it right over that thing
82 years old
um for an amateur your your instinct is
going to be to try to go to the left of
it but if you do that you're in terrible
rough and you're not playing the line of
the hole it's it's intimidating
uh do we know what the offer was from
the live tour to tiger
you know i've seen this number out there
a billion dollars i tend to think that's
probably not accurate
but if phil was getting
200 million
well tiger's got to be more than that
at least a half a billion
you would think
you would think and and um
you know tiger
tiger turned down the opportunity to
play in the saudi international
tournament
at the time a european tour event
um
because you know you could certainly
make the argument tiger couldn't do this
anyway at this stage of his career he's
he's playing three events this year they
have eight
they want to go to 14 next year you're
required to play them all
now maybe they'd make some dispensation
for him
but uh you know tiger isn't going to be
able to to do that but i i do sort of
believe him when he says that uh
you know it just wasn't for him he
doesn't believe in it you know he was
very strong in his comments today
i'll leave you with this the lip tour is
going to be in new jersey coming up and
uh that's bedminster that's donald
trump's course
there are a lot of
people who lost people uh
friends family loved ones and 9 11.
and being in jersey with the you know
the saudi back tour uh
do you think the protest gonna are you
gonna cover that event
i am um
i've been to the first two actually okay
there was some protests in portland as
well
um yeah listen bedminster has the
potential to be volatile
um there there there's potential be a
lot of noise outside of the gulf
you mentioned the 911 connection
there's also the trump connection
the people that support trump and a lot
of people involved in on on his side of
things are firmly behind live
you know trump's been very critical of
the pga tour recently
uh he's not happy that they took a
course uh tournament away from his
courts at doral a few years ago
even though i would argue it had nothing
to do with him it had to do with
losing a sponsor but so you've got
those people who are very very firmly
behind live a lot of people are there's
a lot of people that support it and see
the good in it and see
see positives and then of course there's
a lot of negatives not just based on
where the funding is coming from but
because as tiger mentions today by the
way the saudi thing never came up today
saudi tiger mentioned turning your back
on the pga tour you know guaranteed
money
why would you keep trying hard what
about losing your spot in the majors but
there's so many aspects to this and it's
very polarizing
bob thank you and uh have fun this week
thank you dan appreciate it bob herrick
sports illustrated golf writer author of
the book tiger and phil golf's most
fascinating rivalry released in april